today's topic after yesterday's video in
which a woman was surrounded by 15 dudes
and basically they were going after her
non-stop
i said in the video uh if i was watching
from afar
and i've seen this happen in the late
night hood area gas station
other than calling the cops there's
nothing i would do because there's
nothing i can do
a lot of people felt like that was
cowardly how could you do that
and i'm not gonna lie to you when i
first read some of those i was just like
i was confused that you guys didn't
understand why but i think what i've
come to
understand now is that i think a lot of
people don't understand
what the world is like in some places
maybe you can speak to this because you
maybe have a similar lived experience
i've lived in a lot of places the place
i'm at now
is safe now and it's been safe for a
last little while but
i've lived in places that were not safe
i've lived in places where
there's war there's conflict where
there's gang members that's
common what you guys are suggesting that
young men do when they see this kind of
situation
is often times a death sentence and i'm
not being hyperbolic i'm not being
dramatic
it is extremely dangerous to go up to
men you don't know
in a neighborhood you're semi familiar
with and try to interject
there's so much to break down here do
not play with this stuff there are some
places
i want the young men to understand this
i'm not saying this because i want you
guys to be coward
having values matters but also
understand you have to also value your
life
it matters right you think you're doing
a good thing by jumping in in a
situation where you probably can't help
at all
you're probably going to escalate the
situation and make things work and
you're going to throw your way your life
for nothing
what if you've got kids they're going to
be without a father what if you got
dependents they're going to be without
their sole beneficiary
right the so sole provider right what
about your community all the future good
things that you're going to do you're
going to throw it all away
even firefighters trained people
trained will not throw their life away
to save somebody
why because you understand the long term
as a firefighter they can do more good
if they stay alive so they say like
if your life is in clear-cut danger
there are situations where you're not
supposed to jump in
soldiers in war zones military training
is super important they say just because
you see something you're not supposed to
jump in you need to assess the situation
just because you see a conflict you
can't just charge because if you do
and you get shot in the leg and now
you're just sitting in the middle of a
street stranded and we don't know if
they're snipers or whatever
you put your whole unit in danger you
put other people at risk but you wanted
to be a hero right
it's irresponsible as a young man i'm
telling you learn to swallow your pied
and learn to assess the environment
around you
because it'll be the most important tool
you have prevention
is the best form of self-defense the
amount of stabbings
and fights that i've avoided because i
knew some [ __ ] was gonna happen
i cannot tell you you raise a point with
the firefighters there's some times like
what you guys are saying is that every
fire needs to be put
out right and there are some instances
where the firefighters they show
and they have information yo there are
five tanks of gas
in the basement we gotta go we gotta
leave no i'm gonna try to save the build
that's you
that's you ready i'm gonna try to save
the building boom
no you have to leave and you have to
evacuate everybody out
but you trying to save the building
that's burning that's you
that don't don't ain't no but you were
brave you were brave boo boo good job
but now let's say you run in and so your
best friend runs in after you who's also
a fighter
you guys both die now the fire force is
now without a whole bunch of people that
they need to be able to fight
future fires there's consequences to
these actions guys okay i'm gonna say
this i'm gonna try to be as concise as
possible
violence is not a joke i know you guys
see it on television you see it in
movies
but in places where violence is
prevalent where places where
violence is the norm and violence is the
rule of law
you do not want to be caught playing
with the wrong person because even
though you may value your life and your
self-preservation
there are people that are just looking
for excuses to throw their life away
i know because at a young age i used to
be like that i would fight for reasons i
could not even explain to you i didn't
even understand why i was so angry and
mad at that time
so when you guys come at this and you're
like man well this is
you don't understand these people's
mindset when you're in this situation
the slightest disrespect
can lead to something way more bro i
grew up in the era
where touching a man's air forces you
might remember this
was a potential death sentence this man
came in a club
with white air forces and if you stepped
on it it was a fight
it was a wrap in a crowded club there
were people that would look for reasons
to fight that you would never
comprehend violence said you're like
what happened there and when violence
escalates
adrenaline is pumping you screaming stop
this man's unconscious does not matter
violence turning that wheel that [ __ ]
off
there's people serving life sentences
right now for spur of the moment stuff
for dumb stuff because they couldn't
control their impulses don't act like it
doesn't happen and what are you going to
do what are you
john wick hung back bro who aren't you
neo you're liam neeson from dakin is
that what it is
life is not a movie things real man i've
seen this thing in person
i've been part of it i've been on the
receiving end i've tried to stop things
i've witnessed stuff on facebook live
people losing their lives like it's
nothing i'm
filming themselves doing some of this
stuff they just they can't wait they
think it's funny it's a crazy place out
there let's say you're successful let's
say
you go up to these guys you punk them
you grab the girl they might look for
you because you don't know what they're
affiliated with what kind of lifestyle
they live
they might look this is not a frat boy
at some prep school university this is
inner city stuff this is like places
that
police officers will not even go in some
of these neighborhoods so you you think
that you're gonna go with your
manhood and be like i'm gonna step in
because i could do something
that's dumb police officers would see
something happening would call for
backup
before they would act but you think you
are gonna be a superhero
go ahead i'm not going to tell you how
to live your life you want to live by
those values and throw your life away
that's on you
that's your choice and i'm not going to
but i'm speaking to the young men
who want to act on principle alone
without using their brain
guys just because you see a crisis in
front of you doesn't mean you just act
all right people say stuff if you see
evil and you do nothing then more evil
doing something is not always better
than doing nothing
if you see a fire you just grab the
closest bottle and you try to break it
on it what if there's gasoline what if
there's wine or alcohol in there and you
make the fire larger
do you not understand how when you
interject yourself as a man you raise
the stakes even more
because a man interacting with a woman
is completely different than when a man
comes into it
a woman slapping a man nothing could
happen afterwards and everyone go home
if i go to slap a man in public nine
times at
least 10 times 11 times out of 10. 12
times out of 10
rap i might be fighting with his homies
so i don't even know around
it's crazy to me that some of y'all are
so casual with violence that you think
you understand the ramifications no but
you don't understand i i took like a jiu
jitsu class
in my local uh ymca i don't think you
understand i'm good i'm good i'm good
with it
even mixed martial artists will tell you
in a street fight do not be using some
of this stuff no because the street
fight there's no rules in the street
fight
you're gonna thinking okay i'm gonna do
this and that and then someone's gonna
come beyond around the back
and shank you and then you're bleeding
out and it's a wrap yup there's no rules
there's none
that's the thing you can take all all
those classes that you want
out there in the streets there are no
rules that was another that was an
unfair fight
i was fighting this dude and then this
that was just a street fight
dudes can come out of nowhere there are
no
rules what do you mean two against one
streets
it don't matter if the point is to mess
you up
they gonna try to mess you up that's it
yeah you know being a hero sounds great
you know people tell you
you guys should don't be cowards i'm
like bruh if i jump in and die
who's going to take care of my family
are you going to take care of my family
are you even going to show up to my
funeral
are you even going to think about it the
next day when i'm in the back pages of a
newspaper
probably not but you expect me to throw
my life away for a stranger
when i got a mom who relies on me for
income when i got siblings who will not
make it if i'm not around you think i'm
gonna just throw everything away
what i'm doing is not an easy decision
it doesn't sit well with me i don't see
this stuff and think
man that's not what i'm thinking i'm
just thinking i got responsibilities
what can i do to help the situation
aside from calling the cops
what can i logically do group dynamics a
group of men
act rowdy and they're not gonna let
nobody punk them or show them up
they don't care if it's your girlfriend
sometimes they don't care why you there
people like will you just go and say
it's your girlfriend what if the girl
doesn't react in a way that shows that
she my girlfriend what if she panics and
stumbles for a second then i'll look
stupid
then these guys look like she doesn't
know what the plan is but the thing is
that happened is that you're going to be
going like
hey she's my girlfriend it's going to be
like there's another one that's trying
to bag me yeah i have these
i i don't want that i was helding this
well with my
i don't need a cat you don't know how
she's gonna react see if she
disassociates herself from you
it's a wrap in your head it might work
oh yeah i got this plan right
yeah i'm gonna say i'm her boyfriend
yeah that's not how she necessarily sees
it you're just
another dude and you have to hope she
doesn't know what your intentions are oh
yeah so this dude i'm gonna go with this
dude and then after that
you have to hope that they care
yup cause there's men who don't care if
you got a girlfriend
it could literally be your wife and
they'll still go for it i've heard some
stories about people going to jamaica
not the bat
not not to not to say that jamaica's a
bad but what place whatever
or bad or whatever like that it's just
it could happen anywhere
and i've seen things where the girls
like oh i want my boyfriend and the
guy's like oh
no problem they're not jealous they him
right there
remember that so you knock here let go
pick me over there so
no i mean i'll care bring him here bring
him over here
it doesn't matter the example was in
jamaica that's what it was that's what
happened
but i've seen it happen everywhere oh
i'm not jealous i don't care
in the spirit of moment sometimes you
don't even know what you're gonna do how
you're gonna react
things happen decisions happen things
happen really fast
you don't know how you're gonna react
you might react you might not
but if you choose to look around and you
have some kind of of of enlightenment
and you look around and you see things
are dangerous
that if you really you react your life
might be in danger
yep so what do i do after that they
break my neck they break my back now i
can't walk what do i do next
yep all that because i try to save
someone and now i'm the one in trouble
what do i do now
yeah what if you die in the process now
the person you try to save has survivor
guilt
because you lost your life trying to
save them and you may not have even
succeeded
and the worst thing is that the same
outcome could have possibly happened
if you didn't do but no one would have
would have gotten hurt
but now you trigger someone and that's
the thing we always tell cops to be
accountable
and de-escalate situation but when you
go
up to people that is the exact opposite
of de-escalating a situation and you
might end up with the exact opposite
okay
more fire and you don't want that this
ain't a dancehall
there's no plot armor bro you are not
the protagonist
you are just another minion another side
character a fodder for the most part you
don't know what you're doing in these
kind of circumstances
because if you did you would know going
in is absolute lunacy
nobody who lives in these areas who sees
this stuff on a regular
jumps in and lives a long life i promise
you
you're not you're not you're not living
in some shitty ass neighborhoods where
gang crime is relevant
and doing that stuff and living a long
life the only see
the only way i see myself being able to
step up is if i actually know these
dudes
and be like and know them by name hey
bro yo what's
up bro you good yeah yo let her pass
bruh
you know you know this ain't no thing oh
you always be like that cause i ain't
got the same
but if i don't know them they ain't got
no ties with me
they don't give regrets they don't care
and even if you do know
them that [ __ ] [ __ ] what you talking
about and then you see the shift
even if i still know them still you know
yep
left but i'm just telling you the best
way that i could say something is if i
actually knew them if i don't
if i'm not from the era yo they don't
care about me i'm disposable
in your head you might think you're the
hero of your story
boo boo you're a side quest you know we
have a term for people who just jump in
without thinking we call them heat banks
meaning when you go out and you got a
heat bag with you it could pop off at
any time
there's heat bags on the other side who
probably are costing that women looking
for an excuse to snuff you out
looking for excuse to stop your head bro
i've seen people get knocked out their
head hits the pavement the wrong way
and they never wake up that could easily
be you
if you don't understand the consequences
of violence truly
i don't care how much anime you watch i
don't come care what kind of hero
complex you have
first off all you people with hero
complexes when it pops off you freeze
nine times out of ten when crisis
happens mostly like
like this and i'm not trying to clown
you i'm telling you this because
your expectations and what will actually
happen in reality you need to understand
the difference
you're a tower pop off i don't know man
i thought she was about to do something
listen
when chaos is the norm when chaos brews
underneath any form of civility
i've experienced this when i lived in
ethiopia i've it's the same feeling
new orleans for a short period i lived
when i lived in los angeles
when we were in haiti bruh i'm a 26 year
old man i got people in their 40s who
are panicking in these moments
because they're not used to this kind of
environment and i'm sitting here like
oh you thought you was the man in charge
the moment pops off all
of you grown ass men because they've
never seen it they don't understand
the worst part is that we were the
people that said that they had to
careful for our safety put us up front
in front of all the danger of all the
danger and we
had to deal with it yep the people that
said no because we're doing this for
your safety
but one sh pop off that's right they put
us
first and we had to be in charge and you
have to know man when men's are staring
at you with machetes
they're rolling 30s deep they got
roadblocks and they say what are you
doing here
if you don't know how to manage that
situation or talk to people
they're going to take you for everything
they're going to stab you they're going
to finish you off
they're gonna take your clothes they're
gonna take your shoes they're gonna take
your wallet
and then throw you in a ditch and never
think of you again
that's life in some places that's life
in some places
i'm not saying this to be dramatic or
hyperbolic i'm just saying a lot of you
don't
understand this stuff so when you guys
watch these videos and you're like
this is what i would do i'm like bro go
do it and you're going to live a short
life
you're going to live that's why i don't
travel with people because i recognize
that some people don't know what to do
when they're in a lot of environments
i wanna go to brazil it's cute okay
watch what's gonna happen when you go to
the wrong place
dumb tourists taking gps's through bad
neighborhoods and just following it
blindly because they don't know look
they don't know what they're doing it's
just you gotta think of these things
think of the consequences it's just a
quick story
probably this one's probably going to be
like you know check the patreon if you
want to hear the story
bro every time i've had guns pointed to
my head bro i never saw it coming
and when you in that situation bro it is
one of the
strangest feelings you will ever have
this just idea like oh this
lights can go out any second now you
just frozen slows down it's so strange
and those experiences i was i was
talking to the guys about this i said
those experiences
have shaped me in a way that like even
to this day i have certain like
instincts that are not normal
positioning myself in rooms
always feeling the need to be near exit
if i'm in a crowded place
looking at everybody that comes in and
how they looking around like
there's just so many things happening in
my head and sometimes i'm with people
and they're like yo what are you doing
right now and i catch myself but it's
because i've been used to those
environments so when i see that video
15 dudes you know what i'm looking at i
don't know what you guys were looking at
you know what i was looking at
i was looking at their clothes i was
like okay cool the closest baggie they
could easily be hiding
stuff they're in front of a gas station
late at night some dude's just running
towards their car some dudes
just hanging out odds are a couple of
them slang some rocks probably got a
weapon
bro in my head the calculations are
endless i'm looking at there's any
security cameras
what's the nearest place from like
civilization is this like an isolated
gas station
or is there a police precinct nearby do
police officers even come around here
do i know these guys what colors are
they wearing
what colors are they wearing what's the
predominant color will these guys be
able to recognize me how far am i away
from my place
where if they drive around they come
find me if you're not thinking about
that stuff bro
you have no business talking about this
but you
you just want to jump in go right ahead
and go ahead do it and when they come by
and they shoot up your family
and they shoot up your home or they come
look at you and they just murk you in
the street
then what what was all that for you're
going to call the cops that are not
coming
you know what i mean i got a problem
these guys are chasing me all right well
i hope you run good
young man i'm telling you if you're
watching this please be smart about
these things
do not think that rushing in is a show
of bravery something
because they gonna say you were a hero
for a few seconds and then everyone is
going to feel the absence
of your life and that matters it matters
it's immature to just jump in without
thinking do you don't care about your
responsibilities yeah but i gotta assist
i would never let that's great who's
gonna take care of your sister and
protect her going forward
who's going to take care of your mom you
have responsibilities you got to think
i don't say this to mock you or to say
you're pro it's not that
i want you guys to value life do what
you can that's reasonable
but don't throw yours away because it
affects people around you when you pass
i got homies like last week having being
held up at gunpoint
if they die because they act reckless
that affects me it affects their family
the people that they provide for
you got to think larger so just be smart
about these things that's what i wanted
to push as a message to young folks and
that's our thoughts on this video what
do you guys think what have you guys
dealt with what have you seen
so yeah guys just be smart right that's
all i got to say if you guys like this
video please
like comment subscribe all the good
stuff we want a lot of young men to be
able to see this to avoid violence
when possible we want to find good ways
to be able to protect
women and protect society in general but
we shouldn't do it at the expense of
other people's lives that's my thoughts
[Music]
foreign
i